alright welcome everybody to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here with you guys I have a special
guest with me she'll bring a lot of
energy for the next half hour photo no
vote from polished hustle he's starting
a new YouTube channel in English in
Dutch I don't speak Dutch but we can do
English in Ghana we can work on it no
problem it'll go see he's a loyal
youtube subscriber and follower and
wanted to interview me and so I said
let's do it so we're going to talk about
how you can dominate instead of just
competing so photo maybe give a quick
intro to who you are what you're all
about and then your questions man
awesome awesome awesome well ma'am I'm
just you know basically I'm just you
know I'm just a simple dude man i'm a
simple dude you know from an immigrant
family just trying to hit it big you
know just try and try to make it i just
recently started my marketing from
digital marketing firm in harlot and we
try to help small and micro businesses
grow online um no let's see let's see
how that pans out man weary that's where
did you immigrated from I didn't
immigrate I grew up Eli you I was born
here and all it okay my family comes
from Turkey so that's that's the solder
p this is a lot i mean one of the first
guys that I brought on my team was his
name was a deist nasser eat and use from
iraq but we've been in living in Holland
whoa yeah there's a anyway maybe good
look at that thing man I don't believe
in coincidence is that I don't know
about you but that's that's pretty sweet
I'll have to see maybe you guys can hook
up anyway okay that me questions what do
you got question is no absolutely let's
get into it straight away so let's talk
about competition right I mean they they
they say you know competition is good
for business your competition is healthy
you know what do you think about that um
I think that I think really when I look
at competition
I don't think anybody else can out
Farooq Farouk right I don't think
anybody can out Evan Evan right I see
people trying to do the same thing that
I'm doing with it like what ten or
whatever and I don't like people right
into me all the time I say hey look this
guy's copying your video style I don't
like it doesn't matter if you just focus
on what other people are doing you're
gonna lose if I'm just trying to focus
on shutting them down I'm just I'm just
going forward and what I know that is if
I'm focusing on doing what I can do best
me Evan Carmichael then I'm going to win
or think a lot of people only do a piece
of themselves right so maybe you're
doing YouTube but you also have all
these other passions and interests and
talents the secret is to combine them
all together because if you're only
doing one you're just going to be okay
at it where you could be great and
unique and special and different by
bringing this nobody can combine them
the way you can combine them no no
that's how I look at competition like
for me there's that I have tons of
company so who's my competition other
people posting youtube videos and tons
of people doing YouTube it tons of
authors putting out books you know tons
of people doing it stop oh but nobody
can do it like me as long as as long as
I'm true to me I'm gonna win and so for
the people watching as long as you're
true to you as well you guys are gonna
win it's so interesting that you say
that so interesting I don't know about
if you if you already know that but I
mean when I say you know dominate
instead of competing it's not like I
came up with that stuff right I didn't
came up with that Henry for Henry Ford
said as exact words right that the
competitor to be feared is one whom that
bothers about you at all but goes on
making his own business better all the
time right look I mean look at that and
when you look at me before you know a
jack ma I don't know if you know about
the billionaire founder of Alibaba we've
done we've done videos on a man
exactly exactly he said something
similar what he said like you know you
should you should learn from your
competitive but never copy you know copy
and you die this is exact words so it's
very interesting that you say that right
i meanit's let's be honest it's just you
know it's basically a mindset right if
you were presented if you are presented
with the choice a choice between
thriving and surviving right which one
would you choose which one you know it's
interesting cuz most people choose just
surviving that's why that's why you
hesitated a little that's that's that's
that may be true but I mean it's obvious
that someone would say you know I want
to freakin fry it right I don't want to
survive I don't want to just survive I
want to thrive right and that's
basically what it means why would you
worry about honor my commitment by my
competitor just drop the price is calm
oh I'm gonna put my prize as well oh
yeah he did this he put up a big red
sign saying sales oh let's do it as well
oh I mean that's that's what basically a
lot of the businesses do that's what
competing is basically you know that's
what they do they try to copy they try
to worry about then competitor I mean
it's it's it's very simple right I mean
the look of course you don't you you
have competition right I mean you you
you will have just like you said before
you have competitors of course you have
you know you have to be aware that you
know they're out there and they're
trying to do everything they can to get
your customers and break down your
business and that's basically it tell me
that's that's a reality deficit of the
situation what it in fun and games any
fun and games out there so it's a tough
tough world you know but you know
unconvinced that that's you know only
this is strong with great ethics will
survive in the long run and that's
that's basically what I think you know
you either win or you lose you furyk
menu
bring a different kind of vibe I like it
dude just call it you got a special kind
of energy there man thanks in the thing
so I appreciate it but you would be
right let me necessities of the own is
what yeah you know I think I think I
think everybody I think people would if
you asked them the question thrive
survive everybody's gonna say thrive
you're not they're not taking the action
to thrive all right that's too scary to
thrive because they have to do something
that's different that's not part of the
you know accepted norm because they have
their parents tell them they can't do
that and so people end up just surviving
because you're too afraid to actually go
after it what that thrive would actually
be no that's that's that's so true man
that's so true but but I mean it'sit's
you have to know that you know business
isn't like you you know you know I mean
when you lose a business you don't
freaking eat your family doesn't eat
your team doesn't eat and they have
families they don't eat so so you know
when I say dominate don't compete not
talking about that that you know a
certain type of that you know killer
instinct mindset right I mean you can
only do so much you can only do so much
you know your your competition they can
only do so much right it doesn't really
matter if you want to compete you know
or not it doesn't really matter right
they have a limit they have a limit
maybe the limit this is is much higher
than yours or vice versa it is what it
is you know I mean I believe that you
know while you take 22 people to
entrepreneurs for instance to business
owners you know when you take 12 you
know they have several businesses maybe
you know similar products similar
efforts similar teens similar resources
and one of them will make 10 million
here well the other one will just make
million that's the limit it is what it
is so why worry about you know what my
competition does worry about you it's
about you right you have to constantly
constantly
with everything you have everything to
improve to get better to get more
efficient to get more knowledgeable
about the field about your craft and
whatever happens happens you know it's a
mindset worried about you yeah just like
Jack Ma said well learn from the
competition but compete with yourself
every single day it means so so we've
got we've got Zeno in the chat and zeno
is also from Holland than they saying
hey guys you know you got you got some
Hall in love here hoarsely awesome slow
question coming in from we have some
questions coming from the live body
itself but I know you have questions too
so you want to get interested what's
your you want to go to your questions or
you want to hit the live I'll go do a
mental problem we can switch back and
forth no problem alright so Jay rise is
asking generated again again Jenny
Reisman here I thank you George Jay
rises everywhere easy boy same dominate
it's a fairly masculine word whoo kid is
good business has traditionally thought
of as a masculine place do you feel this
applies to women printers to and this is
this is like a.j wise man what I mean
come on come on let's be real let's be
real je veux okay make it real here I'm
here I'm honest has not nothing to do
with you know male female look there are
you know mothers think about that I
don't know about your situation well my
mom for instance she I mean it's just a
little she's just a little woman little
woman you know sushi she worked many
many years in a meat packing company
right and she would come home she would
come home almost every day she had cuts
on her hands you know faint you might
never never did she complain never did
she complain I can never I can't
remember that she ever ever complained
about that fight I mean you have to do
what you have to do as long as its
ethical I add
because some people scream and yell and
jump you know do whatever it takes you
or do do I work but I'm like man no I
don't want to do whatever it takes I
want to do whatever it takes as long as
its ethical right so it's you know
masculine a mask you know who cares you
just have to do you just have to go for
what you believe then you have to
understand where you are where you want
to go and what you need to do to get
there that's it you can go go at it none
that's it oh alright man what's the next
question hit me that's awesome I hope I
always a rise I hope that helped me you
know i'm saying so look look at it I
mean let's talk about entrepreneurs
who's struggling right now right okay
you know what could you advise them to
do today as a must in order to survive
and thrive a lower questions I a loaded
question I know what you know well it's
it's just more action you know it's like
just it's just take more action it's
just do more right if you're struggling
you got it you got to keep going you got
to keep you know you wanna you know you
want to make your YouTube channel
success right fuuka starters you like
you know I think it's linked up into the
description abilities at the early
stages here there's gonna be a lot of
people who are starting up a YouTube
channel a lot of people starting up the
business and feel like they're
struggling they're not getting it and
you know I'm you know pouring tons of
energy and love into this thing it's not
go you just gotta keep doing it you got
to keep going to make more videos you
know like one video a week is not enough
you got it you got to practice you got
to get better you got to turn you got to
turn the farooq energy into a daily
thing that comes out and get it or do uh
so I think I think people just stop I
think people quit too soon I think
people stop trying looking up eating
then quitting is comes that's what I
some experimenting uh and when it's
something that you really want and then
you're frustrated is actually actual to
want to
to feel like this is just I'm so
frustrated I'm so upset a lot of
entrepreneurs think at some point about
putting in the business and that's when
you need to remember why you're doing
this with what you're passionate about
why you're so excited about it you gotta
keep going you got to do it again like
you know you're you're upset to your
YouTube channel isn't doing better okay
get make more videos get better on
camera you know interview more people
you gotta get a driving it so like
that's the action that you need to do
you have to take some action but it's
also the mindset of just remembering
that this is important to me you know
here's is this why I'm doing it I want
to have an impact I want to whatever
your goal is remembering that
consistently helps keep you helps keep
you going so exactly my vice I mean I'd
sure I understand what you mean you know
I mean Mark Cuban you know I mean this
guy I mean this guy is I follow him as
well I mean he's straight to the point
and east oh he's already there where we
want to be you know so what he said was
like you know sales sure all right i
mean now he's talking of course about
business you know I mean he's not
talking about curing cancer you don't
say so I mean it's basically very simple
right no sales no business that's it
okay you must close deals okay that's
the reality of the situation you have to
ask for the sale I don't know if you
heard about him Alex turnbow from from
from Grove roof is a SAS company
software as a service company and he has
an extremely valuable and Japan
entrepreneurial block maybe you can you
can you can reach out to him and you
know he talks about how they went from
zero basically from a dead stop to over
five hundred thousand dollars in revenue
per month fight every single mom so in
one of his later and one of his last
posts you know he talked about a very
interesting thing right
he talked about one simple thing he did
to close more deals very simple thing
simply ask and keep asking in a
non-obtrusive way okay he talked about
he talked about a potential client right
who seemed qualified and who showed
interest but never signed up for the
footer for the premium gland way so he
asked her what you know he just simply
asked him what you know why I said why
don't you sign up for the premium stuff
you know and the client simply answered
you stopped asking okay this piece of
you wanna sell go figure right so so
clients kinds themselves separate okay
just ask for you as for the way why
wound you why don't you ask for deal a
few product if you really believe that
the product was the best fit for client
right I mean you doing them a favor by
offering at all that's basically how it
is wet stand behind your product and ask
for the deal as for the seal and if you
offer and I mean that's that's that's
another thing you know if your offer is
not the right fit for the for clients
don't sell it don't sell a tune okay
refer them to well to a competitor you
know what you're gonna do I mean they
will trust you basically I mean look
trusting a salad that's how it is they
will trust you more and possibly come
back to you later on with a bigger
budget I mean that's that's that's how
he assails man seals you know the the
problem now is that you know if you
don't know how itself right not
everybody is good at it but I mean what
can you do right I mean what can you do
invest in yourself to be better to get
better at selling or you know just just
like you do you know how you great
people who stand behind your product and
sell it for you on an ethical basis
right that's how I feel what do you feel
badly i like i like i kept trying to
count how many times you say that's how
it is I
like that could be your tagline so it is
this is what is many fee I like your
YouTube banner that's how it is that's
how it is huh that's how it is with
through he's gonna exist always you know
she's gonna tell you his side's that's
how it is alright wanna do is I mean you
may not agree you know it's basically
like this you know I don't really like
to talk about myself that much you know
its just oh you know love me or hate me
man you know love me or hate me but
don't feel and different I don't know
who that was it's someone someone said
it it it's stayed there with me right
love me or hate me but don't feel
different about me but don't feel
indifferent so I'm just gonna put okay
this is how it is this is how far is
this how hard it is do you like if you
like if not if not me that's how it is
you know this is supposed to be an
interview okay let's go give me a
question awesome awesome stuff awesome
stuff look look yeah you in one of your
posts Ivan you said you know the
traditional sales person needs to evolve
Oh will die right so let's talk about
that film it done yeah I think so it's
something I talked about in the book I
think when you start when you start
selling something you're talking about
the features right right your base
selling and then somewhere along the
lines you learn about you gotta sell
benefits you're not selling feature you
selling benefits now and that's how much
the world cells where if you look at
people really broken three look at
comforters have really broken through I
they use what I call core selling where
you buy from that person or you buy from
the company because of who they are and
what they represent so you know why do I
buy why do I buy a Nike shoe maybe it
has the wedding buddy maybe has the best
quality you know maybe you know maybe
you know they have the best laces or
whatever but what is are they
advertising that is that what they're
really pushing its when I put on a Nike
shoe I feel like I'm Michael Jordan or I
feel like I'm LeBron James and so I feel
like
feel like a winner right like trying to
put that emotion into it that's that's
how it is you know so it's not the
features it's not the benefits and so
every company and every salesperson has
to do a better job of explaining why
their company is here what their company
stands for you know I'd go to a whole
foods and I just assume everything in
there is healthier because it's that
whole foods so I'm willing to go there
and I'm willing to pay a premium right
the you buy anything a whole foods it's
thirty percent fifty percent more
expensive than somewhere else exactly
but I go and other people go because
they just feel like Whole Foods is a
healthy brain and so we're sales people
are falling down is that they're only
trying to close a deal with features and
benefits but not talking about the
deeper why the deeper connection to the
company that these potential clients
have and so when sales people stop
selling and start listening and start
using storytelling Farooq is a natural
storyteller here right when sales people
start storytelling right then they start
to win I mean exactly i mean put a face
on it what's the story behind the
company that's why I you know I'm really
you know I'm just you know put me so
many you know somebody in the mountains
you know with my gum you know with my
wood my way where we put me somewhere in
the mountains with my gonna sound like
you know you know like like let the
people in Alaska sunk in the day hunts
hunters and gatherers right you know
hunters and gatherers you know with you
know wife and kids you know with a
couple of goats with a couple of you
know chickens running around and when
they need me they just go and hunt and
they bring to me I'm sinful dude but I
knew that like you said before right
people why I mean they're like kind of
my company is a digital marketing firm
right there are like thousands more than
7,000 companies in Holland alone who can
do what I do basically
why would someone say hey why would I
you know let me highly that you know
that I follow then we highly polished
awesome digital that's my fur Mendenhall
let me hire them why I needed to put
myself out there you know you have to
get a story you know what's what's the
face of the cabooze the face of the Cubs
just like steve jobs they would Apple
right he was the face he put himself out
there it's something very very out of
the you know I mean it's very
uncomfortable it is very uncomfortable
but it is what it is you have to get out
of your comfort zone people have to say
you know what man i got like 20 offers
from 20 companies man butter and his
team man these guys I know who they are
I know what they believe and I know what
is therefore i know the energy i know
they wanted help me out really like you
know you can't do that without you know
with just you know sitting behind your
desk and just putting out facebook at
noticing so with this video and i'm
really investing helio a lot that's why
i started myself with that personal
branding thought putting myself out
there so that my clients my potential
clients when they look me up when they
one day when he tried it you know when
you everything down every offer down I
want to be the ones that just stands out
massively just like the big elephant in
the room right it can freakin they can
go around me Matt they can't go be you
know under me not above me they have to
face what they have to accept me right
that's what I that's what I believe you
have to get you had to get yourself out
in right listen I think if you put faruk
in a room he's gonna stand out no
daughter knows that's what businesses
and that's what business is all about
that's what this is all about if people
don't know you how are you gonna show me
how are you gonna sell you have to stand
out and not everybody's gonna love me
now that man is gonna like like like
maybe the way I look me not everybody's
gonna live my beard who cares who cares
right I don't give a crap
I don't give a crap here's how it is we
know I know we can help you out look
this is the price and I would love to
help you out people take it on even
that's it that's how I believe it you
what no no no no that's the way it is
every every every thought that's the way
it is okay it is what it is it's noisy
when you got what's the next question
when we talk about selling Ivan you know
there's a concept called social selling
right social selling you know a lot of
people get that one I don't know if you
familiar with that term social selling
okay why do they get it wrong are you
are you aware of that Thun social
selling yeah that concept yeah I mean
some I mean a lot of a lot of companies
a lot of brands they think that just you
know by posting discounts you know
offers you know product we got this
product on silver got that product on
sale on social media right they think
that by doing that they think its social
selling right I mean it's so freaking
funny man it's so funny what do you
think about people doing that uh I think
it's I think I think people treat it
like a direct mail I think people treat
it like right just direct marketing you
know just just you know you are putting
this out how many people see it how many
people buy it and just track and
conversion of each one where you can get
some but think about from from a
consumers point of view do they want to
subscribe to your Twitter feed or
Facebook feed or YouTube channel if all
they're getting is promotions you know
some people might oh well some people
might you know like if I if I want
coupons for whatever some people would
but it's much more effective if you can
use as a storytelling platform to get
people to care about your message to
feel like they're aligned with what your
company is all about it's about decor
selling right and have eighty percent of
your content
being related to your theme your message
whether it's inspirational or believe or
whatever it is to make me feel something
related to your brand by them and then
you can have something okay we launched
this new book or we launched this new
shoe or we launched this new drink or
whatever it is right people now are
attached to your brand instead of just
coupon clipping so I think people I
think people just I think a lot of
brands are just lazy I think they're
starting to get a little bit better but
most brands are this just like big
companies are slow it's just what they
do so they've sucked that for the most
part I mean social selling right but
they were slow and everything they worse
loading on the internet they were slow
to get on TV they were slow to get on
the radio you know like they've been
slow that's what they do they're slow
yeah right so it's always that's the
opportunity for entrepreneurs if you
talk about dominating to the computer
net exactly where the eyeballs are right
how many brands are really really doing
well on YouTube right now you know not
that many so no this is your chance to
be able to stand out and be different
from your competition you said it
beautifully man you said a beautiful you
absolutely right I mean social selling
writers I mean it's it's it's really
simple man it's really really simple
right social selling basically needs you
leverage all online activity to find a
potential client to reach out pitch and
close a deal that's basically how it is
I don't know if you know about Jack Jack
kosakowski from creation agency and
Jamie shanks from sales for life you
know they have some great awesome
content about this was just our viewers
to check them out maybe we could you
know post the links for them below give
him some love you know jack recently he
was future than any any video on the
YouTube channel of phonetics media I
don't know if you know about you know I
mean it's very very beneficial very
short but extremely powerful video about
social selling so uh maybe you know if
you if you post some links in the
description area below maybe Oh
he was connected check them all this
very very valuable very interesting
stuff you know uh Evan I want to talk
about why why right people scream and
shout you know also also you know do
whatever it takes you know become a
billionaire a trillion out a little
tight in there you don't say why why not
so my question to you a visit what's
your why not i get i get just insane
love when I feel like I'm helping
somebody uh one of the things that
bothers me a lot is untapped potential
right right I mean somebody playing
smaller than they are frustrates me uh
wow that's neat man whether that's with
the interviews or just meaning
entrepreneurs or just live day to day
people that you come across zeen
somebody with a lot of talent that's not
living up to their potential just
bothers me uh on a personal level and so
I try to fix it and the way that I can
do it best is through entrepreneurs
because that's what I have knowledge of
you know you might be a truck driver and
playing small and you know I don't know
much about the truck driving industry so
I may not be able to help you as much as
if you want to start your own business
really um but that's that's my why I
want to feel like I'm making an impact I
want to feel like I'm helping people
reach their potential um well that's
what I get excited by every day man
that's that's deep man I mean a lot of
people you know they hold themselves
back just like you said that they hold
themselves bad man it's really you know
that's reality people hold themselves
bad man i know from from myself right we
hold ourselves back we hold ourselves
back why would I for instance today man
today I I made calls to potential
clients right
I you know I'm calling I need pick up my
day pick up basically they don't say a
thing it will say you won't cause like
you know like the screen movie right not
saying anything I'm not hello this is
far you know the basically said nothing
I had that twice happened to me I'm like
man and these people are it seems like
the active but it's very strange how are
you supposed to get a customer if you
one don't take up your phone to you pick
up a new haircut you know even a screen
movie or something like that so I don't
get it that one one client I was
speaking to her and she was like I was
prepared to the proposal white i was i
was saying like man we would love to
help you out we would love to help you
out he has a minute might we have a
minute because i know you what I can see
is you don't have a website right so she
was like boom no not interested you
don't need it you know I'm not mad I
tried I tried it three times right you
don't know me I don't know you I
completely understand why you act like
that I'm not give me minute let me
explain no yeah I'm not matter what the
house but that is going on and and then
they they decry about why does my
business survive instead of thrive why
am I constantly constantly having issues
with paying my bills why am I not
getting enough Kyle's right I'm not then
you don't get out of the cutting of look
of your comfort zone and you don't
invest in the things of today today and
tomorrow online is the way to go and
these people don't even have a website
so I'm not Mandy but you know what for
me I love that rejection man why I you
know give it to you say to me get out
get out I don't want to hear you I don't
want to see I don't want to see you I
want I want to hear you voice I'm not
mad that's awesome that's awesome why
because the more I get rejected the more
i can get to my what
my yes to the yeses right that's that's
why I want I want I want to get through
down through those knows I don't know oh
how much noise do you get every day yeah
that's the way it is man that's the way
it is Farooq called oh oh how much we
have to be doing at rejected man how
much notice do you hear everything every
single day I have a different model man
i do zero selling its all inbound i put
out the content people find me that's
how I that's how I roll but dude it's
freezing out it's crazy how half an hour
goes fast man for people who want to
find out more about you oh my god is
this visit man is this it michigan
optima oh this is young oh I got up
things like I I had a lot of things that
I want to talk about what your month
hopefully we can discern more often
matter what do you think we'll see man
but i want i want to give you shadow
people want to learn about you where are
they going man you can find me you can
find hopefully we can get to get some
links in the description box below you
know you can find me on polished also
calm you know i have a newsletter that
an exclusive news data when I talk about
my journey from boom from 0 to 33,000
plus a month you can subscribe there you
can find me on twitter at polished also
on instagram polished on the score
hustle and you know let's connect i want
it i want to connect with people who you
know who have to you know that the great
ethics great normals and we just want to
reach big big things better if i can
help you out i would love to help your
let's connect things a bit further think
big was for it all right thank you guys
for watching thank you prefer the
questions teen told a lot of guys
whatever your own one where it is i will
see you soon let's good